yes i partially grew up in Los Angeles
on the Westside I know with my mother
only my father's in Tennessee okay they
separated yeah it was generally it was
good it was tight you know we was loving
from you know with her older brother and
a younger sister it was a family
orientated it was really really love
what I did was after I graduated out of
high school I went to college and and
after college ended up getting married
having four sons I started teaching
school for a while and then transferred
employment became electrician from that
my mother was sick so I came back from
the Bay Area I was I was in San Jose and
I came back and just working why my
mother was alive and I have made massive
heart attack twice so they had to fix
her vows
and I started veering away from my
family and started hitting the streets
of LA and realizing that this is where I
grew up at so I knew a lot of people and
people were starting to make fast money
so I enjoyed that
you know I stepped off into that life
and got into the drugs affiliation I
there was a group of guys that I hung
with that we did not sell drugs in the
neighborhood we come down down and sold
in downtown faster quicker and no one
knows us and we would leave every night
you know with a pocket full of money and
then as things got greater I started
staying staying one night after another
night days weeks doing the same thing
and soon later I became my best customer
I started using the drugs and drinking
feeling comfortable with the
homelessness but didn't really care
because I had a couple of friends that
we associated affiliated with and we
interacted I really truly didn't care
we went from hotel to hotel from the
Huntington to the frontier to the Roslyn
and then I said we had big money like on
the first to the third we would go to
the Cecil you asked me about stories
about the what I experiencing throughout
the years
it's unbelievable what a heart and eyes
could see in yes I've seen I've seen a
lady that was on seizure in the frontier
give him in oral sex and she had a
seizure if she climbed down and a jaw so
they called the ambulance they brought
them both out there to get a thing to
break her jaw to release the release her
at the same time the pressure off his
penis but at the same time I was
standing about four feet from the
ambulance when they were doing it cuz I
was looking and blood went everywhere
they had to tie off the blood for the
circulation from izi for she bit his
Peters penis that I'm that it that is a
most unbelievable things you could ever
see in your life because I've seen
people shot I've seen people stabbed
I've seen people cut I've seen the
person lose his eye over using
somebody's pipe but to see some man
there howling and screaming and they a
mass has done they're not doing doctor
they're doing the best they can to stop
the circulation and so he left on the
ambulance
she left in Hamlin's we saw him about
four days later with a bag on his leg
with the ambulance I mean with the
hospital uniform own talk my work he did
get a hit we were telling him the girl
that uh that bit your bitch'll penis she
gonna be getting out pretty soon if they
arrest her but I don't think they did he
says that uh she's upstairs and Roz no
way no me neither
it blew my mind why are you still filly
ating with her I so many seen a guy as
for a pusher to push his pipe and he
pushed his pipe with a with a coat
hanger and after he he took a hit the
God told him that he OEM a hit because
he used the pusher and he took he took
the coat hanger and started stabbing the
guy in the neck and the throat because
he didn't have nothing to give him there
are many stories that I could tell you
it but you know the one that really
stays with me for all my life and will
always stay with me is the frontier well
we used to go every morning to a chicken
place right on fifth and spring and it
stays open 24 hours a day and then they
had a big pickle jar it was empty
and people will put five ten twenty
dollars in and you circle the floor
whatever floor the person body gets
thrown out of then you can get the money
if nobody's thrown out that day that
money stays in the jar I've won three
hundred dollars I've been doing
somebody's life I bet I've won nothing
on this a lot of times because I'm
guessing the wrong floor estimate about
forty or more there there has been not
from the management because if you had
any faculties anything you rent the room
a lot of them don't have door knobs let
them do the sheeting being clean been
changed as she's it the sheets are
blacker than your shoes you got roaches
running around you got rats in the
hallway telling you hello good afternoon
good morning the elevator don't work you
have to take the stairs
when the process going into the frontier
we always there you go you go on your
risk your own risk so you better have
somebody with you sometimes I take a guy
with me even though I they're
prostitutes and girls all in the hallway
and all up and down on every floor I
always have a guy with me because I've
been there on the bed
and I turn the bed upside down just sick
because it was so nasty and dirty and
getting ready to hit the pipe and the
door swing open and this guy wants to
rob you for whatever you got but for
there take your shoes and take your
chain and they think whatever you have
and you can't chase them down because
you don't know what floor he went to and
them and if he went out the building
nobody sees anything that was just
experiences that's a frontier but the
great experience is that I had the Deaf
was called the Indian alley that's
located on 5th and Los Angeles toward
towards Maine right in the middle of
block is an alley and it goes from 5th
Street to Winston that's where the Law
Center's mission used to be located and
back of the Los Angeles mission is where
everybody go there to get high but at
the end of the alley down on Winston
side is the Indian section at a building
if if you didn't get robbed in the
process of behind La Mission if you go
there by the Indian now that you're
definitely gonna get robbed and they're
gonna take everything and I mean
literally everything pants shoes shirt
you know especially your drugs so
everybody will walk down Wars Oh Los
Angeles Street and they come in come in
on Fifth Street because if you go down
Winston and go into the alley you know
you're gonna get robbed they never come
down
into the in the middle of the middle of
the alley but they just be waiting for
people to take take their wrist and walk
through there I've seen it the Indians
have machetes all we had was just iron
sticks and little pipes or milk crate or
something and we sit up and get high and
sell drugs but they were down there
doing strong-armed robberies and
sometimes cutting people and if you call
the police the police to tell you not
may hurt it's not my area is not my
district they would go but if we can go
down Indian alley they knew what was
happening they knew that the loss of
mission would be breakfast lunch and
dinner and after dinner time that alley
becomes like a rock concert you'll see
the lighters flashing and you see the
people interact and dancing and drugging
but never go down on the other side and
they sit there and I mean groups of them
10 15 20 Indians pure Indian American
Indians they'd be sitting there drinking
their alcohol and shooting up their hair
on and looking for somebody because they
don't have any money and they were
trying to get the dollar bill best way
they could that is my greatest
experience but throughout my experience
in Skid Row where the lady told me to
she told me that I want to come into my
my place and I was looking for where she
was talking about and she had a a porta
potti with carpet on it shag carpet had
the radio television set up in there
and she wants you to come into a porta
potty to have sex
and in the Smail by itself you just
knock your socks off
you know because about it's under bleep
I'm forbidden sexual Pig yes and she
used to do that then she turned around
and she made three porta-potties they
were all together lined up on 6th Street
and they were on 6th and st. Julian and
they would line up going towards Wall
Street and it beat about ten of them
lined up and she she's just the first
three were hers
the first three were that you can rent
them out or you could use it for with
her it makes it yeah she rented her
mouth she that changed at the time of
when he had a mayor coming down to a
tour through Skid Row and she asks him
do you want a date he was dressed in his
normal in the Levi's and t-shirt okay
not before Garcetti okay
he that same night the following day to
removed all the porta-potties out of
Skid Row because of that um I've seen
guys that are you unbelievable students
from USC college come downtown and going
to any of those stores or block on
Broadway and they come out they lost
their bicycles
that's the Hobby that they're still
going on today
Abby burn yeah that is that is a basic
survival kit we call it a survival kit
when you can't hustle you can't get
nothing else go up on Broadway spring or
heel snatch a bicycle bring it down here
someone would buy it yes that is uh yeah
what happened was
I was filler ated I was joining with her
work several brothers that were in the
gang activity I came to my senses I was
drunk and I had a four-day binge and I
was I mean I just left a couple of
chicks freaking or whatever and I came
on Fifth Street staggering and the body
wanted to shut down so I laid down
literally laid down on the sidewalk and
trying to get me some sleep
and two today I don't know who the guy
was but I do know one thing he saved my
life with the power power but he kicked
me in my ribs and he and he kicked me on
my leg and I was trying my best to get
up and when he called me a no-good
[ __ ] you're an [ __ ] you need
to get the [ __ ] out of here get away
from front of this building I rolled
over and started throwing up in the
street and I'm on the curb laying down
and he was standing over it curse to me
I stopped throwing up and I set up and I
asked man above if you take this from me
I'll serve you whatever it is take it
from me I had I have turned up my heart
was already hard now with a WDC that
means we don't care okay I didn't care
about the police department I didn't
care about the system I didn't care
about anything I was the only caring
about my life I didn't care about my
children or anything I just broke them
out of my brain don't even exist and in
the process of that 24 hours I got up
and went around the corner on Winston
set on a cardboard box asking myself how
stupid can you be
and at the same time I said just give me
one more try one more try and I
guarantee you I guarantee you with the
breath I breathe I would serve you about
a couple of days later I go into st.
Vincent's Cardinal Manor I stayed there
for about six months since I'd never
went outside I was still evaluating my
life getting myself together at that
time I went for my first walk outside
and I noticed that this might be Skid
Row and it might be a special community
but it is a community and I said I'm
gonna do my best to make it a community
instead of a wayside and from people to
male like I've done made mistakes and
error says you shouldn't be making I
ended up not using any detox with me
myself I searched myself every day to
make sure that I've taken my first foot
and my last foot but in a positive note
I realized that I have to do something
so I just started to move walk around
when I have my eyes were focusing on the
dollar bill prior to this how can i
hustle how can i nibble how can i get
some money now my eyes is completely
changed to Lane and I'm focusing on how
can I help someone how can I take
someone's life reform them and change
them now I don't want to be like me but
I want them to be best the best they can
be
I didn't know so I walked through Skid
Row walking to school and I came back to
the park and I was leaning against a
fence and the guy walked up to me and
said where can I take a shower
and I said you needs it more to the
shower brother you've humid he said yeah
well I've been on a train and I've been
and I've made it down here on Skid Row
now I gotta change my pants without
[ __ ] in my fans I said well you need
more than a shower and I told him to go
across the street and see if they give
you a shower or you might have to go
down to midnight or the Union but
somebody would give you a shower and
that's when I realized that I could be a
beacon of light for people so I set up a
table didn't know what I was doing at
first setting up a table talking to
people asking me you know how can I help
you a lot of people at that time we're
dragging about give me a dollar bill you
know give me a cigarette that I was
trying to hustle me
I then it started molding almost a year
go by and I was over at Grand Central
Market just sitting there and I learned
the hustle about the Grand Central
Market is that if you get there between
hours of 5:00 and 6:00 that you're
really close down all that leftover food
they sell dirt cheap you don't normally
wouldn't with pay for five hours you
only pay 50 cents or a dollar they just
wanted out of the tray so I usually get
lots on your chicken you know I'm just
sitting there filled it got three plates
right here and I'm just grubbing you
know I didn't paid two dollars I'm just
grub and have myself and this woman was
sitting right behind me and she said she
represent she was talking to another
lady she represents Skid Row and they
got to go voting on some property that
they want to convert over to start
building construction and I looked back
and I see this Caucasian lady up in age
and I asked I said I said where do you
stay she said I stay in Buckner at
Bunker Hill and I said oh that's on the
other side of Grand Central Market right
there she says yes I said when's the
last time you've been to skid row
she said I never I said well were you
why are you voting for skid row I'm on
the downtown Executive Board of downtown
neighborhood council and I just kept
eating and then my spirit says hey maybe
I need to inquire about that so what I
did 14 years ago I went and to the
voting poll found out about the
procedure put my name in a ballot
I wrote a little little story about
myself and I was elected by the peers of
Skid Row
there was the largest turnout they ever
had I just got elected again last year
and 2,200 people voted for me that are
homeless that live in Skid Row but
walked all the way to to seventh and
flower to vote or caught the bus but
2,200 people took the initiative to do
that
when I became me down to our neighbor
council the first thing I did was to
record making them recognize that that
we are somebody and no matter what the
situation is if you shake your tree
you'll find somebody in your family it's
as homeless so if don't treat the one
that you don't know but you're
definitely not treating the one you do
know so why don't you treat everybody
that's the same so and that means giving
respect so I intervene in vain and
walking then I realized that we didn't
have no handicap crosswalks most of the
signal lights were at 3 or 3 minutes
then of the streetlights were very poor
and a lot of blind spots and throughout
the last four years I've met with
different agencies throughout the city
for street maintenance
two street construction and now right
now I can literally say that in the 40
blocks of Skid Row I think we got thirty
seven blocks covered with handicapped
crosswalks all the lights in Skid Row
has been adjusted with new paper new
lighting so there's no blind spots at
all throughout the area but the most
important thing is that people are being
recognized that it is a problem in
homelessness no one graduated out of
high school said they want to be
homeless
they and even myself went through that
part of mental health where you depress
things you used to have you don't have
no more your family that you thought was
you got your back don't have your back
and the friend said to call friends they
ignore you you mind become a concrete
barrier where you blocked in and they
say mental health I say it's just a form
of changing and you have to reach ange
that's like a child being taught how to
walk you have to be retaught how to live
again and appreciate housing appreciate
the things that you used to have you
have more respect for them now in the
present day yeah you have to diligently
love yourself yes
you just don't value yourself that's
right they they value others but don't
take the time out to value their self
it's like it's a guard that you put up
and some people say mental health when
you see individuals yelling and
screaming or whatever acting up real
loud know that there's nothing wrong
with them being in middle hell they just
don't want to be bothered and they don't
want to no interaction no communication
just need me along and let me do what I
do love is the greatest key of it all if
you learn how to love yourself and you
realize that there are rules and
boundaries and everything we do in life
but when you realize is that all this
laws that are said in front of us our
myths if you don't take the time out to
love yourself because when you love
yourself you appreciate the law not
cross jaywalking you appreciate the law
I'm not messing with drugs you
appreciate that say excuse me
that is correct that is very correct yes
no I don't know I I just know that I'm a
beacon of light and nothing more
important is to see someone get a door
key I have last year I received a war
from the city well several rewards I've
received from danger man award I'm in
the afro-american Museum for that award
I am a field reward for the city for
doing got 241 people house last year
wouldn't no help from other agencies
just me calling landlord me calling
owners say take a chance for someone
give an opportunity for a person that
that is in Skid Row wants to change
their life they want to a fresh start
the greatest one that I just went
through the experience is the lady miss
MS glass she got her apartment in the
process of getting her a one-bedroom
apartment
she turned right around an apartment was
furnished and I thought it was lovely I
looked at it I saw it was great at
better than what I got I mean with a
half kitchen counter well it was clean
of marble floor I mean wooden floor
buffer and shining big old couch in the
living room the landlord calls me and
tells me window you need to come over
right away I thought she was just maybe
throwing a tantrum maybe she was cussing
someone out or maybe she's just doing
her thing I get over there and all the
furniture that was supposed to be in
furnace in the unit even a brand new bed
and the bed frame was outside down the
side of her building and I'm knock on
the door and asked her what's up so you
told me nothing you gonna come in and
I'll get ready come in to talk to her
and I see this big old tent it's a
living room floor that's
that's a tacky I can't go in there I
said when she come outside let's talk so
I told the landlord to give me a give me
a little space for a broom and let me
talk to her and I explained to her about
the rules at least these property
the furniture is belongs to the owner
and we're putting it in your unit and
and if you don't want it in your unit
you need to get in contact with them and
let them move it since you moved it out
you have a your own car garage and you
but you don't have a car once you put
that furniture in the garage and as you
start to feel comfortable start moving
it back in but if you know what you need
to do is to take that tent down girl you
know as he told me I can't sleep without
the tent I said maybe
downsize just take a look just think
about it I'm not asking you to do
anything you can't do yourself
just think about it right now that's
been almost two months and the tent is
still up in the room but the bed is back
in there so see wasn't it and that's
what I'm working that really amazed me
thank you very much I'm glad I'm glad to
be able to help somebody